the dupmp Sammy Wilson thank you so much
for joining us just your reaction to
this news uh broken uh by Sky News last
night that King Charles was being lined
up to have a meeting with Ursula
vondeline today that is no longer taking
place but certainly a very interesting
development that number 10 was in talks
with King Charles about having some
involvement in this new deal with the EU
your reaction to that
well we were totally amazed first of all
we thought this couldn't possibly write
and there was it appeared that yes this
was actually planned
um
we concluded that not only is the prime
minister naive if that's what he was
planning to do but this is a cynical use
or an abuse of the king but he knows
feel well that amongst our supporters in
Northern Ireland there is a great regard
and a great respect for the king as
there was for the Red Queen he knows
that the king's intervention would be
seen by many of our supporters as an
endorsement of the deal and he also
knows of course in doing so he was
dragging the king into a hugely
controversial political issue not just
in Northern Ireland but even within his
own party you know it was in his own
party there or we've already seen great
difference of opinion and yet here he
was
um that payers prepared to drag the king
into that controversy the only
conclusion we can come to is that he
knows that in these negotiations he's
hasn't achieved the objectives he set
out for himself and his own party uh nor
has he achieved the promises that he had
made to ourselves and was now trying to
get the king to try and pull the thing
over the line for him
there's no suggestion that King Charles
would have taken part in any ceremonial
role but certainly what does it tell you
um about the potential relationship
between number 10 and Buckingham Palace
that this was being muted as an idea
well man I don't know if it's it was
just naive are they or desperation
um I would hope that the the powers who
have given a short shrift very quickly
and then the um Downing Street have to
pull back from it but you know the the
the king knows and in fact he made it
quite clear that he would withdraw from
some of the things which he'd be
involved in whilst Prince of Wales
um because he knew that there had to be
absolutely absolute political neutrality
and the possession of the monarchy and
um you know why guiding Street would
even have considered in the first place
involving them uh we don't know other
than that they're not desperate to get
this deal over the line a deal which is
splitting the conservative party and the
daily uh which
um they know will be controversial in
Northern Ireland
there's a three-line whip for Tory MPS
to attend the commons on Monday it is
highly anticipated there'll be some sort
of announcement over this new brexit
deal has the dup been consulted over any
potential new deal
I mean I think it's already known that
officials and the Prime Minister have
spoken to uh members of our party and to
Sir Jeffrey Donaldson on a number of
occasions
um we may have seen all the improved
information which has been in the the
press and a lot of it has been leaked
any higher it has been discovered even
by your own program so we have some idea
of what's in the take but the one thing
we do know because there's been no
indication at all that the
prime minister Andy ever got around to
addressing the Democratic deficit which
the protocol causes Northern namely that
EU law is imposed on us without any Say
by um politicians and by the assembling
Ireland and we also know that um EU law
and it's it's imposition on Northern
Ireland is going to drive us further and
further apart from the rest of the
United Kingdom and we have very clear
all along it that's the essential in
Radium and the deal now if the the Prime
Minister succeeds in getting out we will
embrace it but um if he hasn't succeeded
in achieving that aim then as part of
the United Kingdom we could not accept
it because we expect that British law
should apply in Northern Ireland because
we're part of the United Kingdom not
Brussels law imposed on us and with
other disasters effects at hand
that there does of course have to be
some sort of compromise in any
negotiation uh what are the chances of
the dup agreeing to this new deal
briefly please
well I mean the one thing that a a
conservative and unionist prime minister
cannot compromise on is the Northern
Ireland remaining part of the United
Kingdom no unionist prime minister can
ever agree to the splitting up of the
United Kingdom and essentially the
protocol does that as a as it exists at
the moment because it makes us subject
to foreign law and a foreign Court
rather than be part of British law and
British courts
okay Sammy Wilson we appreciate your
time today thanks so much for joining us